when it comes to architecture the sky is
truly becoming the limit there are
currently four Mega tall buildings in
the world which measure at least 600
meters about 2 000 feet skyscrapers have
typically been Office Buildings but now
many are being offered as homes bringing
new challenges for Builders at 1550 feet
the just completed Central Park Tower is
the tallest residential building in the
world with some of its 179 Apartments
reaching more than a quarter mile into
the air Brook Silva Braga got an
exclusive first look at what's at the
top
all right this is it welcome to the
penthouse how high are we we are roughly
at uh 1400 feet high the pain the
penthouse in Central Park Tower is now
the highest residence on Earth so this
is what we call the observatory for a
reason okay every room's an observatory
its asking price is also in the clouds
250 million dollars so it's three
stories how many square feet this
apartment is 17 500 square feet that's
big seven bedrooms eight bathrooms two
kitchens private Terrace we're legit
looking down on the Empire State
Building you're actually looking down
Joaquin Stearns works for Excel
development the towers Builder it costs
about three billion dollars to make this
place yes if you include the land
correct will it turn a profit yes
let's hope so
Stearns spent nearly a decade building
the tower and the last month staging the
penthouse now he's looking for a
billionaire who sees height as the
ultimate form of beauty this is no
different than an art piece whether it's
a collectible or a piece of art you're
going to pay whatever you're willing to
pay for something if it's meant for you
if this sculpture in the sky counts as
art what makes it possible is
engineering if you want to see really
where the magic happens you have to go
through behind the scenes right we are
behind the scenes skyscrapers can be
unpleasant to live in because they
naturally Sway in the wind oh here we
are so just below the roof Builders hung
this 1200 ton weight called a tuned Mass
damper to counteract the movement of the
building how does it know how to move so
it's a passive system meaning that it's
like a pendulum so if the building is
moving a little bit one side the
pendulum moves on to the other direction
the design for the world's tallest
residential building this was an early
study model came from Architects Adrian
Smith and Gordon Gill this could become
the signature of the building they've
done this sort of thing before how often
does someone come in and just say can
you build me the world's tallest
building I think we've had that about
eight or nine times Smith designed
Dubai's Burj Khalifa had more than 2 700
feet it is the tallest building in the
world and together Smith and Gill
created a Jetta Tower set to shatter
that record until construction was
halted in 2018 by the Saudi Arabian
political perch do you think it's going
to get finished yes if it does the tower
will rise a staggering 3 300 feet but
everyone wants to know how high can we
go you know today we might be able to go
to a mile hi
but we don't know yet is it a short list
of things that worry you about going
that high or it's like 12 things it's
the unknowns that worry me temperature
shifts at the height from the ground
plane to the top of the building it
expands and contracts differently wind
Behavior characteristics that's a big
thing right the winch how much can it
sway before it starts to be a problem in
an office building it's a little more
forgiving than it is in a residential
building if you have a swimming pool
or a bathtub full of water the
psychology around watching that move
it's a little different yeah computer
modeling has helped and so this is put
into a huge wind tunnel this is a
mock-up of the kilometer High Jetta
Tower and so what you're looking at is
how to move that wind around the body
you look at little subtle things in
these balconies in the body of the
building for example that's to help kind
of confuse the wind
for most of the 20th century only two
buildings in the world Rose above a
thousand feet the Empire State and
Chrysler buildings today there are more
than a hundred why so many now first of
all we have the technology to build
higher and concrete that's stronger we
have better pumps to push the concrete
up elevators go much faster than they
used to it is booked super tall
architect Stefan Al traces the history
of the skyscraper this building kind of
took it to the next level explaining how
zoning laws often drove design buildings
could no longer go straight up one air
is rules forcing narrow tops the next
yielding tall boxes next to open plazas
now residential skyscrapers are on the
rise along with some concerns we've
already had a lot of reports of problems
for instance trash shoots when you open
them they sound like an exploding bomb
or that people get stuck in elevators
for too long when the tower sways too
much we spent parts of two two days at
the top of Central Park Tower one of
them quite windy and never felt the
building sway but with outdoor
temperatures just above freezing opening
and closing the Terrace door
was a bit of a hazard wow oh and there
was this high-pitched sound ringing out
when we entered the penthouse we hear
this sound right now is this must be one
of these you didn't know until you built
it type situation no this actually
happens to be a normal kind of we call
it a growing pain if we have a window
open you might hear that in a very very
cold day but some buyers may not care or
even know what it's like to live here
luxury real estate is often used by the
world's Rich to park money because
unlike other Investments the purchases
can be made anonymously critics also
complain the tower casts new Shadows
deep into Central Park's main Recreation
areas all to benefit a building that
nearly two years after it started
selling units has fewer than 30
full-time residents I want to tie it all
into like one thing that I want you to
respond to why should resources in real
estate be used in a building for the
point zero one percent why is this a
good use of a scarce resource regardless
of who they end user is you know you're
creating additional housing you're
bringing jobs you're bringing tax
revenue yes you know a buyer group that
may be considered a certain level but
that group is not necessarily taking on
all the resources of the infrastructure
of this city usually hardly any of them
because they aren't here but in return
in return we're bringing a lot of
Revenue to the city the tallest
buildings have rarely been the most
popular at least at first are you afraid
of heights uh not yet just don't look
down they've risen because tenacious
developers and daring Architects my
goodness pushed higher than the Skeptics
thought wise if my math is right this is
the highest place you can stand outside
Asia
I think you're about right fifteen
hundred fifty feet above New York you
can't help but notice how rare that
still is
for CBS Saturday morning Brook Silva
bracket New York
superficial statement man what have you
oh you imagine standing up on top there
and just looking over
I mean you know what would be nice if
all those billionaires would just open
up their Apartments to all the people
who need a place to live
affordable housing we need more of that